♪ ♪
>> Sean: SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER MITCH McCONNELL
DECLARED THAT THE CLASS WAS
CLOSED ON THE MUELLER REPORT
EARLIER THIS WEEK, BUT THE
REPUBLICAN LED SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE HAS
SUBPOENAED DONALD TRUMP JR.,
WHY?
PRESIDENT TRUMP RESPONDED
EARLIER TODAY.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> MY SON IS A GOOD PERSON.
MY SON TESTIFIED FOR HOURS AND
HOURS.
MY SON WAS TOTALLY EXONERATED BY
MUELLER.
WHO, FRANKLY, DOES NOT LIKE
DONALD TRUMP, MEAN, THIS
DONALD TRUMP.
AND FRANKLY, FOUR, MY SON, AFTER
BEING EXONERATED TO NOW GET A
SUBPOENA TO GO AGAIN AND SPEAK
AGAIN AFTER CLOSE TO 20 HOURS OF
TELLING EVERYBODY THAT WOULD
LISTEN ABOUT A NOTHING-MEETING.
YEAH, I AM PRETTY SURPRISED.
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW WITH
REACTION AS A SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER MITCH McCONNELL
HIMSELF.
THE DUDE SEE YOU.
YOU HAVE CALLED THIS PARTISAN
PARALYSIS, BREATHLESS CONSPIRACY
THEORY, UNHINGED PARTISANSHIP,
GROUNDHOG DAY, A SPECTACLE, STOP
RELITIGATING A 2.5-YEAR-OLD
ELECTION RESULT AND MOVE FORWARD
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I AGREE WITH ALL OF THAT.
WHAT IS SENATOR BYRD DOING, DID
HE NOT FOR YOUR MESSAGE?
>> I THINK THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
HE HAS ALREADY INDICATED THAT
THE COMMITTEE WILL FIND NO
COLLUSION, BECAUSE THAT WILL BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
I THINK THAT THIS IS GOING TO
HAVE A HAPPY ENDING.
I UNDERSTAND THE PRESIDENT'S
FRUSTRATION HERE.
BUT I THINK THAT THIS IS JUST A
BLIP, I THINK THAT THE CASE IS
CLOSED.
I THINK THAT THE CONTROVERSY HAS
BEEN CONCLUDED.
I DON'T THINK THE HOUSE THINKS
THAT, AND THEY WILL CONTINUE TO
TRY TO STIR THIS UP.
BUT ENOUGH, ALREADY.
WE HAVE FOUND OUT FROM THE
MUELLER REPORT THAT THE RUSSIANS
WERE DEEPLY INVOLVED IN IT.
THERE WAS SOMETHING LIKE 18-20
INDICTMENTS OF RUSSIAN COMPANIES
AND RUSSIAN INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
TRYING TO GET INTO THE CAMPAIGN
AND TO MESS WITH IT.
I THINK THAT IT IS OVER.
I THINK THAT IT IS TIME TO LET
IT GO AND MOVE ON AND TRY TO
DEAL WITH PEOPLE'S BUSINESS.
>> Sean: SPECIFICALLY IS THAT
YOUR MESSAGE TO SENATOR BURR?
>> THAT IS MY MESSAGE TO THE
PUBLIC, THAT IS OUR VIEW THAT
THE CASE IS CLOSED AND IT IS
TIME TO MOVE ON, AND I BELIEVE
WHEN THE SENATE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE FINALLY DOES REPORT,
WHICH I THINK WILL NOT BE TOO
FAR DOWN THE ROAD FROM HERE,
THEY WILL REACH THE VERY SAME
CONCLUSION.
>> Sean: YOU CALLED YOURSELF
THE GRIM REAPER OF THE COUNTRY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
A >> Sean: WHEN IT COMES TO
THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
EVERYTHING WILL BE FOR FREE, SO
WE ARE TOLD, BUT WE WERE ALSO
TOLD THAT YOU CAN KEEP YOUR PLAN
AND YOUR DOCTOR AND SAVE MONEY,
THAT DID NOT HAPPEN.
MILLIONS LOST THEIR PLAN.
THE DOCTORS AND EVERYBODY PAID
MORE.
BUT I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO
POINT THAT YOU ARE MAKING, THIS
IS NOT CONGRESSWOMAN
OCASIO-CORTEZ, WE HAVE
CANDIDATES.
HOW DO YOU ASSESS THIS GROUP OF
20 PLUS DEMOCRATS THAT WANT TO
BE PRESIDENT?
>> EVEN THE ONES, SEAN, THAT
DECLARE THEMSELVES MODERATES.
WITH REGARD TO HEALTH CARE THEY
SAY THAT THEY WANT THE PUBLIC
OPTION.
THERE WILL NOT BE ANY PRIVATE
HEALTH CARE INSURANCE IF YOU
HAVE A PUBLIC OPTION, BECAUSE
THE GOVERNMENT WILL ALWAYS SELL
YOU THE INSURANCE CHEAPER.
SO NO MATTER HOW THEY CHOOSE TO
CHARACTERIZE THEMSELVES, YOU CAN
BET WHETHER IT IS JOE BIDEN,
BERNIE SANDERS, OR SOMEBODY
ELSE, THE NOMINEE FOR PRESIDENT
ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE IS GOING
TO BE ON A PATH TO TRY TO TURN
AMERICA INTO A SOCIALIST
COUNTRY.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO LET THAT
HAPPEN.
DONALD TRUMP IS STILL IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND AS LONG AS I AM
MAJORITY LEADER OF THE SENATE, I
GET TO SET THE AGENDA.
THAT'S WHY I CALL MYSELF THE
GRIM REAPER.
WE WILL NOT HAVE THE GREEN NEW
DEAL.
WE WILL NOT HAVE MEDICARE
PROGRAM KNOWN AS LONG AS I AM
MAJORITY LEADER OF THE SENATE.
>> Sean: TELL ME ABOUT AND
TELL US ABOUT YOUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE PRESIDENT NOW.
I KNOW THAT YOU SAID WE ARE NOT
GOING TO DO HEALTH CARE THIS
YEAR, BUT I KNOW THAT MOST
AMERICANS WOULD LIKE HEALTH CARE
FIXED.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
PORTABILITY IF THEY CHANGE JOBS.
I PERSONALLY LIKE EITHER HEALTH
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS, IS A
HEALTH CARE COOPERATIVE WHERE IT
IS $50 A MONTH ON UNLIMITED CARE
IN WICHITA, KANSAS.
DR. JOSH NUMBER.
WHAT ARE THE TOP AGENDA ITEMS AS
WE CLOSE OUT THIS YEAR AND MOVE
INTO AN ELECTION YEAR?
>> OUR CHALLENGE AND DOING ANY
KIND OF HEALTH CARE REFORM NOW
IS THE DEMOCRATIC HOUSE.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO AGREE TO
THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO DO THAT YOU
MENTIONED.
THE PRESIDENT ESTABLISHED THIS
BUSINESS TO FORM SMALL GROUPS
FOR PURPOSES OF BEING ABLE TO
ALLOW GROUPS TO PURCHASE
INSURANCE LIKE LARGER COMPANIES.
AND A NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS AT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
TRYING TO DO THROUGH EXECUTIVE
ORDERS, BUT LOOK, YOU KNOW WHAT
THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO DO.
THEY ARE RUNNING THE HOUSE.
THEY WANT TO HAVE MEDICARE FOR
ALL.
WHICH IS ACTUALLY MEDICARE FOR
NONE.
DOING A DEAL WITH NANCY PELOSI'S
HOUSE IS A REAL CHALLENGE.
AS THE PRESIDENT HAS POINTED OUT
ON HEALTH CARE, WHAT HE WANTS TO
DO IS TO COME UP WITH A
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE CAN ENACT
WHEN WE GET THE HOUSE BACK AND
HOLD THE SENATE IN A SECOND
TERM.
>> Sean: TELL US ABOUT YOUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HOW YOU WORK
TOGETHER.
TELL US MAY BE THINGS THAT YOU
DID NOT KNOW ABOUT HIM, THAT YOU
NOW BY ASSUME THAT YOU TALK WITH
HIM REGULARLY.
TELL US ABOUT IT.
>> WE TALK ON ALMOST A DAILY
BASIS.
WE HAVE BEEN ON THE SAME
WAVELENGTH ALMOST ALL THE TIME
THAT HE HAS BEEN THERE.
WE ARE TRYING TO TAKE AMERICA IN
THE SAME DIRECTION.
AND I WANT TO COMPLEMENT THE
PRESIDENT FOR THE EXTRAORDINARY
SELECTION.
HE HAS MADE FOR JUDICIAL
APPOINTMENTS.
AS YOU KNOW, SEAN, THE BIGGEST
CALL I MADE IN MY CAREER WAS TO
NOT LET BARACK OBAMA FILL THE
SCALIA VACANCY DURING THE
ELECTION.
>> Sean: I GIVE YOU A LOT OF
CREDIT FOR THAT.
MANY TIMES.
>> THE PRESIDENT DID NOT BLOW
THAT OPPORTUNITY.
HE SET UP NEIL GORSUCH, AND THEN
WE FOUGHT OUR WAY THROUGH A
HIGHLY CONTROVERSIAL
CONFIRMATION OF BRET KAVANAUGH,
BUT IT IS NOT JUST CHANGING THE
SUPREME COURT THAT WE DID.
WE ALSO WERE CHANGING THE
CIRCUIT COURTS.